I've now run out of video footage once
this this video goes up and so this is
going to be the very last of my 10 short
vu videos on whatever topic this one is
focused on critical thinking that's what
the rest of the the usable videos that I
have that I could put into some sort of
thematic arrangement have to do with
some of these are from my students some
of these are from people who are
involved with the vu network and stay
tuned after this for some discussion
about how I plan to continue doing these
10 short clips videos because I kind of
liked the format and I know some of my
viewers like the format too and I'm
going to solicit input from viewers I
don't want them as comments on this
video I'm actually going to put together
some way in which people can write to me
and and submit comments either using my
facebook page or some other means so
here are the last of the the vu videos
this will be the last of the low-quality
older hair down videos and I hope you
enjoy them
why did you have to learn all those
fallacies well just to pass my test and
get out of my class right isn't that the
whole goal of everything in college just
to get it done and get the piece of
paper well you know I ask yourself why
do we make you do the things that we do
in college over and over again you get
it the first time the second time you
get it without reinforcement would you
actually learn all these things on your
own the fallacies have been studied and
have been talked about for some of them
you know for only a few hundred years
some of them for over 2,000 years and
the reasons why or because there are
certain bad forms of arguing and
reasoning that keep on popping up over
and over and over again and people keep
getting suckered by them and smart
people generally I mean smart people
sometimes do get suckered but smart
people generally don't get suckered and
ignorant people or people who are you
know not paying attention to things or
people who have not developed their
skills to the level that they should or
people who are stubborn or people who
are you know it's not one way or another
foolish they get suckered and they get
suckered precisely by these sorts of
techniques that's why we had all of
those great examples that you can see
not only in your textbook and not only
in the problems that we looked at but
also in the video lectures that I i
prepared for you guys or carried out in
classes some of you actually contributed
some some really good examples to me too
but you see this happen over and over
again that why are why are we so
concerned with these fallacies because
you are going to run into them over and
over again in your life and you are
going to
to address them
exactly 542 no actually that's a joke
that's a good question because if you
look in different textbooks for critical
thinking or different source books they
have different numbers of fallacies and
they sometimes use different terminology
there are certain basic ones that that
keep coming up like for example the the
ad hominem fallacy but you notice our
textbook actually broke that down into
several sub fallacies and it also
distinguished the genetic fallacy and
I'll tell you right off the bat the way
our textbook distinguished the genetic
fallacy is not precisely the way that
another one that I've used before in the
past does it as well so you might say
well you know that doesn't sound very
good you know like these critical
thinkers who are putting together these
textbooks can't actually agree on how
many fallacies there are and what sort
they are and there should be some
consistency between them it's really
just a matter of how they decide to
divide them up because you could take
the same fallacy and if you look at it
very closely you might actually break
into to try to do this there we go to
different fallacies there's kind of
mirror image chair two different
fallacies which then you could talk
about a greater Mike and there are some
things that perhaps ought not be
considered fallacies per se as much as
mistaken positions because they're not
really so much arguments and our
textbook had a few of those
you know so there really is no no actual
numerical answer for you how many
fallacies are there what's the exact
number but we can distinguish different
families of them that help
so this is another question from one of
my critical thinking students what is
the difference between the fallacies of
composition and division well what do
they have in common first they're both
fallacies it means they're bad arguments
that means they also have a certain type
to them a certain structure and that's
why we give them particular names what
do these two fallacies have in common
well they both have to do with holes and
parts or members and groups and you can
go from parts to the whole or you can go
from the holds of parts and in both of
them you're attributing to one a
property or a characteristic that you
don't have good grounds for thinking
that it does have so if you're going
from the parts to the whole that's
composition if you're saying that
because the parts have a certain
property the whole therefore must have
it when you don't have good grounds to
think so you're committing the fallacy
of composition if you're going the other
way and you're saying because the whole
has a certain characteristic the parts
must have it when you don't have good
grounds for thinking so then you're
committing the fallacy of division so
just to give you some examples if you
say we put all the best players together
onto a team there for that team is going
to be the best team you don't actually
have good grounds to think so because
teamwork and you know being able to work
with each other all of that is required
for the whole that the team is so you'd
be committing the fallacy of composition
if you say well the Green Bay Packers
are all from Green the green bay packers
is a team is from Green Bay therefore
all the players are from Green Bay
that's a certain characteristic you're
attributing to them not the case that's
the fallacy of division
so this is a question from one of my
critical thinking students and she is
asking how much does down play and by
that what she means is one of the
rhetorical techniques or or tropes as
they're sometimes called in other areas
how does that affect important decisions
well what we mean by down players there
look our textbook is talking about our
ways in which we can without entirely
discrediting a person sort of
de-emphasize their achievements or their
capabilities or their relevance or their
credibility for example the book has a
great one where somebody's saying yes
you know I I have a yellow belt in this
martial art and my sister she's a mere
green belt well that mirror and if you
know about martial arts yell yellow belt
is even the first one after white belt
and then you work your way up green belt
is higher that mirror gives the
impression that she has lesser
capabilities or capacities or
credibility do these affect important
decisions yes in a lot of different
areas in politics which is very
important in the marketplace in our
economic decisions we use these in
personal relationships and our arguments
with you know spouse's boyfriend's
girlfriend's friends family members all
these sorts of things there's a tendency
to use rhetorical figures sometimes
knowingly sometimes unconsciously where
else the workplace yeah the workplace is
very important also even in scholarship
you know we may dismiss each other
because we think that somebody else's
research is not quite as important and
if you're skilled with rhetoric you can
you can do this quite easily using these
types of wood so it is very important
that's a good question coming from one
of my critical thinking students mr.
Sims who's actually asked to really good
questions is an opinion always
considered to be biased well if it's
somebody else's of course but if it's my
no no that's that's a joke no opinions
aren't always biased if you have some
good grounds for why you're holding the
opinion it's probably not coming from
from bias of course your grounds
themselves could be could be biased it
all depends on what reason you have for
holding that opinion and sometimes you
may not have any reason some sometimes
here's one kind of bias right some
people are opinionated they're stubborn
they they're in love with having their
own opinions well that's always going to
be biased right but no not all opinions
are biased
so what is a bad inductive argument this
is coming from one of my critical
thinking students and I'm not going to
give her any trouble about not knowing
the answer to this after the entire
class because I'm guessing that
three-quarters of the class probably
doesn't doesn't quite remember all of
the ins and outs of this let's start
with what is an inductive argument so
inductive arguments are those which have
to do with with probability not with
necessity likelihood and you can make
them stronger you can make them weaker
you can add things to them they admitted
some exceptions they're more like a
dimmer switch than they are an off on
switch in that you can you can make them
stronger weaker by adding or taking
things away what makes an inductive
argument good or bad well a good
inductive argument has to have goodness
in terms of its structure how its put
together and in terms of the starting
points or the premises actually being
true so there's two ways in which it
could be bad you could have the
structure not being set up well for
instance when you do hasty
generalization right you're working
you're doing it an enumerative induction
and you are generalizing from too few
cases that's poor structure that's
poorly set up it could be that your your
premises are actually false for instance
if I tell you that your spouse came home
last night while you were away and he
had lipstick on his collar wreaked of
perfume had a somebody's phone number
tucked in this pocket and a pair of
panties in the other you could
reasonably infer that there's some
cheating going on right however well
that would be you know as far as a form
goes it would be okay what if I'm lying
what if the information is not good well
then that would be a bad inductive
argument right
okay another another question from one
of my critical thinking students this
needs some context for those who aren't
in the class to know precisely what's
being asked about target population is
when you're making an enumerative
induction when you're making some sort
of inference about a large group that
you haven't actually observed and you
don't necessarily have data on when
you're making an inference about that
large group that's the target population
the sample is the part of the group that
you're actually able to look at the part
you observe and when you make an
inference going from the sample to the
target population or another way of
thinking about it is going from the more
specific to the more general what you're
doing is you're saying that because we
know something about this small part of
the group we know something about the
group as a whole so when we do opinion
polls for example and we pull a thousand
people or 10,000 people about their
their likelihood to vote for a candidate
we're only observing that that portion
right that is the sample and the target
is the whole set of possible voters who
we don't observe we don't actually know
until they show up on Election Day which
way they're going to go and actually
sometimes they'll they'll even lie when
they come out of the booth so they the
exit polls or sometimes not even correct
can the target so all that background
information is helpful can a target
population and the sample group be the
same no but the sample group is part of
the target group isn't it because you're
taking a portion of the target group the
target population and you're sampling it
that's why we call it the sample and
then you're generalizing about the large
group so they can't be exactly the same
but they they do overlap to some extent
right because the sample group is
part of the target popular
is there a big difference between hasty
generalization and stereotypes so hasty
generalization is a fallacy when you
carry out a inductive operation in
reasoning and you do it on the basis of
two few examples too few for the sort of
thing that you're investigating you know
so for example you don't need to dissect
an awful lot of pigs to know that they
have livers because physical things tend
to be pretty similar but you if you want
to know something about psychological
traits of human beings and associate
them say with ethnicities or with work
groups or with religions you actually
have to look at a lot of people you
can't just go by the first one or two or
even ten that you come across hasty
generalization fits into the larger
phenomenon of stereotyping but not all
hasty generalizations are about
stereotypes and not all stereotyping is
a matter of hasty generalization
sometimes you know in the formation of
stereotypes what's going on is you carry
out a hasty generalization you meet one
French person they're rude you meet
another French person they're rude you
know made a third French person they're
rude and you conclude that all French
people are rude and that that would be a
hasty generalization it would also be a
stereotype right now what if instead you
were told by people that you know or buy
movies or buy books that French people
are rude and now you meet a French
person you say aha that person is going
to be rude because they're French well
you're not doing a hasty generalization
then what you're doing is something
actually much more like a deductive
process of reasoning and I think that
this is actually a really good question
and I am going to discuss this
specifically in a dr. Sadler chalkin
talk so thanks for the question
hardest critical thinking question that
I've announced so far what is a good
website to go to when judging someone
like a news reporters credibility and
the hardest because there is no one
single website that you would need to go
to for news stories or fax or things
like that there are some watchdog sites
factcheck.org could be an example of one
you know you see certain stories or
certain statistics or facts being
bandied about and they actually do the
research to see whether those are true
but sometimes you have to wait a while
for them to actually do the research and
you don't know if they're covering
everything too that's that's a problem
with that but does that get in an
individual reporter or an opinion former
no not exactly so what could you do well
you could start by googling googling
them you know their full name along with
keywords like bias commitments opinions
arguments relationships see what sort of
things come up and if you know some of
the things that are red flags start to
come up you find out that they are
deeply committed to a particular
political ideology well that's probably
a bad sign but there is no one single
rule of thumb for this so you've
actually asked a question that I'm kind
of stumped by so
well I have to say I'm not a big fan of
conspiracy theories in general because
they they do tend to have the same sort
of structure just inserting different
content and there's usually some
fallacies going on in it one of the most
prominent is well you know it could be
this way and you haven't proven that
it's not this way so therefore it is
this way or it could be this way and we
don't have all the evidence for that but
if we did have the evidence for it
somebody would want to keep us from
having that evidence we're showing that
evidence so therefore it is this way and
those are essentially different
formations of the fallacy that we call
appeal to ignorance or argument from
ignorance I mean they can be more
sophisticated than that and there is I
mean there are some some conspiracies
that actually do come to light but the
burden of proof is on the conspiracy
theorists to really really make their
case and they have to do it in part by
showing that the the standard story is
in fact wrong and I don't see the the
ones for 911 actually successfully doing
that it seems clear to me that we are in
a conflict and not just us but for a lot
of others as well with something that I
would like to call totalitarian Islam
rather than his Lama fascism or anything
like that some people call it radical
Islam
since I do a lot of work in fascist
studies and studies of totalitarianism i
prefer the term totalitarian Islam it
seems clear to me that that one group
within that that ranged that spectrum
did in fact set up the coordinated plan
and hit the towers and the Pentagon and
I don't have any problem believing that
so
so I've given it a good bit of thought
and reflection and I decided that the
best way to solicit new comments and
questions which then I can assemble into
more of these 10 shorts with higher
quality production of course would be
for me to create a YouTube video
specifically about that it's sort of
like a a forum where people can post
comments using the the YouTube Google+
comment interface and then i will i'll
look at them and those that i think are
worth putting together into new videos i
will i will do from there so don't put
comments for new ideas on this video
what you want to do is put it on the
video that I'm going to be linking to
with an annotation here